A sadly, Dr. Deborah Berk's now retired, became an
unfortunate node of disinformation during her work
for the Trump administration on the coronavirus
pandemic. And you might remember the clips of Dr.
Berk's repeating how smart and thoughtful Donald
Trump is. She would repeat falsehoods about the
reality of the virus. She would make obviously
false claims about how well things are going here
or there, thanks to Donald Trump. And many
of us did not fall for it, although some did.
Now, Dr. Burks has retired and she did an
interesting interview yesterday with CBS's
Face the Nation. And she sort of came clean
about the Trump administration's handling
of coronavirus. And we're going to look at
some Krip clips, not Cripps. We're going to
look at clips. And this is all fine and good. I
mean, she's telling us things we all suspected,
but it's too damn late. The time to sound
the alarm would have been 10 months ago
when clearly she knew Donald Trump was in over
his head and this was being mishandled, coming
clean when Trump's gone and you're retired and we
have too soon to be three or even four vaccines,
it's too late now. It's still interesting in a
car crash sort of way to hear what she has to say.
Asked if Donald Trump was merely distracted
from the virus, which is deadly enough,
Dr. Burke says there were actually people
in the White House who actively thought
the coronavirus pandemic was a hoax, where
they're covered deniers in the White House.
There are people in the White House
and I think people around this country,
because I've had the privilege to meet them and
listen to them and hear them, because I wanted to
hear what people were saying. There were people
who definitely believed that this was a hoax.
Why? I think because the information was
confusing at the beginning. I think because
we didn't talk about the spectrum of disease,
because everyone interpreted and what they knew.
And so they saw people get covid and be fine.
Now, she almost blames herself there. We didn't
talk about the spectrum of of disease as if
that would have changed the minds of the people
telling Trump not to worry about this. These
were people committed for political reasons
to claiming or believing that it was a hoax.
And it's horrifying. She presenting other data
was not going to make a difference. And Dr.
Burke's in this next clip, claims that despite
the fact that she was the coordinator of the White
House covid task force, she basically never saw
Trump in the spring or you gave an interview.
What we're seeing today is different from March
and April. It is extraordinarily widespread.
And then President Trump tweeted,
he blasted you for saying that. Did
you ever speak to him after that?
I hadn't seen him for months before that or
a month after that. But that was like that
was the coordinator of the Khobar Towers.
An extraordinary moment, because I also
got yelled at by the speaker who I am, which
meant I mean, obviously, when you have gone
through a lot to get in their positions, I have
tremendous respect for women and women leadership.
Speaker Pelosi said she didn't have confidence in
you because you were working for President Trump.
So I don't have confidence in anyone who
stands there while the president says
swallow Lysol is going to kill your virus, he'll
kill you and you won't have the virus anymore.
And so that was very hard because I
have known her from the HIV world.
So, again, the big news, Berk's hadn't seen Trump
in person for months before that, nor after that
covid coordinator not seeing the president of
the United States. Trump simply didn't care,
which we knew. She's just confirming it. A asked,
how the hell did Trump get covid arguably the
person who could be the most protected? They
were supposedly testing everybody every day.
And Dr. Burke says nobody at the White
House wore a mask. Take a listen to this.
But how did the task force allow the
president, who calls himself a germophobia,
to get covered himself? How did that happen?
They were only two people who regularly wore
a mask in the White House, myself and Tyler and
McGuffey, the support person that I had from HHS.
So the staff around the
president was not wearing a mask.
He's the commander in chief.
This is a national security risk.
How is that possible?
I think people believed wrongly that testing,
testing would be adequate. How is that
possible? I think they believe that
testing is a surrogate for a
public health intervention.
But did you see the president? The
United States needs to wear a mask.
Did you press Mike Pence on that? Did you
press Mark Meadows, his chief of staff?
There are multiple communications about masking.
Yeah, this tells you a lot.
And again, we suspected this stuff, but to
hear her say it is both, again, too little,
too late, but stunning to hear that this degree of
incompetence surrounded Trump here. She explains
that someone was giving Trump grafts that weren't
coming from her. She doesn't know who it was,
but somebody was giving Trump other data.
And by data, I mean pictures essentially.
Do you think President Trump appreciated the
gravity of the health crisis you were describing?
I think the president
appreciated the gravity in March.
It took a while after I arrived in the White
House to remove all of the answer, Larry, data
that was coming in. I mean, there was parallel
data stream coming into the White House that were
not transparently utilized. And I needed to
stop that. We're assuming outside advisors,
outside advisers coming to inside advisors. And
to this day, I mean, until the day I left, I am
I'm convinced there were parallel data streams
because I disinformation. I saw the president
presenting graphs that I never made. So I know
that someone or someone out there or someone
inside was creating a parallel set of data
and graphics that were shown to the president.
I don't know to this day who parallel
data and strange graphs and charts, huh?
Not unique to the pandemic within the Trump
administration. I think we all remember the
Hurricane Sharpey incident and other instances of
bogus data and graphs. So all of our suspicions
were true. And that's why this happened
early, Trump didn't take it seriously after
April. He also didn't and no one at the White
House did. That was in his immediate inner circle,
the people taking it seriously, like Dr.
Burke's to some degree, although she did play
a role in perpetuating disinformation. Dr.
Fauci, they weren't even talking to Donald
Trump for months at a time. And there were people
at the White House who believed it was a hoax.
This is the full story and it explains everything
that went on perfectly clearly. They disbanded
the pandemic response team. They threw out or
ignored the pandemic response playbook left behind
color coded by the Obama administration. They
weren't wearing masks at the White House. They
weren't talking to Dr. Burke's. Trump wasn't. And
Berk's coming clean now is great, for the record,
but it didn't help it all back then.
Is there a silver lining here? There is
knowing the degree of of disregard that
the Trump administration had for the virus
and seeing how Joe Biden is actually taking this
issue head on from day one suggests to me as if
we didn't know from all of the examples from
New Zealand and Rwanda and Taiwan and others
that having a federal administration folks
focused on this will make a really big difference,
like things got disastrously bad in the U.S.
and they got that bad with total incompetence
and disregard from the Trump administration.
Now that we have people paying attention to it,
I am even more confident that it will make a
huge difference. Could Dr. Blix and Dr. Fauci and
someone else maybe have come together in May and
publicly denounced everything that was going on?
Yeah, maybe. I don't know. And again, the question
that I have is I don't know what happens if they
do if they all get fired and get replaced
with total sycophants. Burke's kind of became
a sycophant by by exclusion. By default. Foushee
did not. But he was pushed out to a great degree.
I don't know if they all come
together and say, this has to stop,
this is what's going on. They may all get
fired and get replaced by the equivalent of
Dr. Scott Atlus in all of these positions. But
nothing surprising whatsoever in what Dr. Deborah
Burks tells us would have been nice for her to
say it a little bit sooner for sure. We'll have
more coverage of this on our Instagram page. You
can find us on Instagram at David Pakman show and
you can find me on Instagram at David Pakman.
I posted some interesting things over the
weekend that you may find enjoyable
or horrifying, depending on your
predisposition. Quick break. Back after. The
David Pakman Show at David Pakman Dotcom.